Africa is the riskiest place for a woman
to have an abortion with a highest rate
of abortion related deaths in the world
this week campaigners from around the
continent attended marches to demand
access to Safe abortion care in many
African countries abortions are either
illegal restricted or stigmatized still
they are common but often clandestine
this endanges women's lives and health
and that's why rice groups say safe
abortions are the way forward
[Music]
in nullarigu Northern Ghana some women
have been speaking to DW
someone would just give birth then
um three three months or five months
time the person will get pregnant and
she cannot take care of that child and
the pregnancy at once when people see
that you are pregnant and you want to
abort they will be calling you
prostitute or they will be like oh this
thing is a sin or it's against the will
of God without knowing the consequences
behind it I think there will not should
respect women's decision because it's my
body I can choose when to give birth and
I can choose when to give birth to my
own kind
and what these campaigners are calling
for safe abortion can be defined as the
termination of a pregnancy by a trained
provider in sanitary conditions using
modern techniques
in Nigeria to look at just one example
nearly half of all abortions that women
get are unsafe this is partly because
terminating a pregnancy is only legal if
the mother's life is in danger DW's
amaka Okoye met two women who are
suffering because they couldn't get safe
abortions
[Applause]
anime puts away her laundry at the
crisis shelter she calls home
she used to live with her Uncle a pastor
he raped her continually
she has had eight abortions all from
untrained providers odome worries about
what these unsafe abortions have done to
her body
at some point I was scared for my life
at some point I was scared that maybe
these practices might
damage my womb or something I was scared
that
I might die at the process you don't
want to know the amount of heat I had
for myself
I
for so long I hated myself that happens
to
us
Dorothy in jamanza founded the shelter
where onome lives she's a well-known
activist helping survivors of sexual
violence
she also Champions a course that's
rather unpopular in Nigeria
access to Safe abortions for all
women can only legally get an abortion
here when the mother's life is in danger
Manza says that's not enough
abortions are needed
in the cases of rape
you don't force people who have been
raped that have been exposed to that
trauma to keep pregnancies arising from
rape we have high levels of suicides you
know from people who are forced to keep
pregnancies from rape on our watch list
now majority of the people on suicide
watch are minors
in Jamaica and her staff are making web
videos about safe abortions they are
targeting a younger audience because
Germans says girls also need this
information
as I see children carrying pregnancies
to them that have no business you know
carrying pregnancies and then we're
looking for people to fix them
Nica gave birth as a minor she wanted an
abortion but couldn't legally get one
the birth cause catastrophic damage to
her body
two years later she still hasn't
completely healed
I give a vaginally but then they had to
cut down to the end and they babysitted
still didn't come out so they had to
pull her out
after after a week the nurses found out
somewhere around the open so they had to
they had to close it back
most times I feel pain there sometimes
you feel itch around that side
but all these things would have happened
if
I if I had that abortion service
dinner the crisis shelter
the women here feel safe
was not safe they say is restricting
access to Legal abortions
South Africa has arguably the most
liberal abortion laws on the continent
despite this more than half of all
abortions there are still unsafe
endangering women's lives let's meet one
nurse trying to change this
my name is I'm a professional nurse I
work at maristops I've been appointed
since 2017 as a provider I was allocated
to do termination of pregnancies which I
was so excited to help our women
there are days where I'm found in the
clinic where I need to assist patients
face to face but I'm most of the time
allocated on telemed you're speaking to
them
[Music]
at the same time have you ever been
pregnant since 2020 called when coveted
us I would say telemedicine is the one
that is
taking over my daily routine there are
those who are in the rural rural deep
rurals of South Africa so where they've
got no option even if we are far you
don't need to come closer to the center
or you can you don't have to be face to
face with the provider you can be
consulted telephonically and we send a
medication you do everything at your own
pace in your own location where no one
will ever even notice that you've ever
been to Mario stops everything is going
to start within four hours so you need
to cover yourself as a kid the
medication will come with one pill of
termination which is called mediprist
there will be four pills which are
called cytotecs and there will be one
pack again with painkillers then you
tell them how to take the medication
after three weeks you advise them to do
a pregnancy test
we have lost a lot of women because of
this back street abortion so as my rest
stops came in it has also assisted a lot
where it where it has given women a
chance to an option to decide what they
want we have seen much improvement in
maternal death that has been happening
through to Backstreet abortion
women have got the right to decide on
their bodies and women have got the
right to decide what is good for them
and as I was logging we don't have
babies by chance we need to have babies
by choice so we're trying to cut off the
stigma of abortions I also have my
family members who take me as they call
me names I've got friends who think they
will never do such Why am I doing that
we've got people who come with placards
showing how we're killing babies and all
that but that it's not that the reason
why we are doing it we're not there to I
don't feel like I'm killing anyone I
don't feel like I'm committing any crime
to me I'm assisting someone who's in
need of a service abortion is a need in
our community
abortion is I need there's no woman who
can be raising a child just because
they've got no option just because they
are afraid of the stigma so allow
everyone to do what they want and we
thought People Like Us
that we will have a lot of people dying
discuss more on safe abortions I'm
joined by onike she's a physician and
maternal Health researcher based in New
Jersey in the U.S welcome to DW news
Africa now what are the key uh things or
factors that make abortion so risky in
African countries
uh thank you for having me at the macro
level the primary driver of risky
abortions are the restrictive abortion
laws in many countries in sub-Saharan
Africa more than three quarters of women
live in this context and these laws
ultimately determine Health policy the
funding and the health infrastructure
available around abortions the second
main thing is the societal stigma around
abortion and unintended pregnancy
particularly outside of marriage this
affects how women are able to manage
their reproductive desires and obtain
safe care when they design abortion
so does that mean that changing these
laws could make abortions safer for
African women
do you think so I think ultimately to
make abortions safer for African women
we do need
governments to change laws and policies
in country however that said changing
laws is insufficient primarily because
of the stigma associated with abortion
at the societal level and so in addition
to law change governments need to make
sure that they're actively
um delivering interventions and programs
to Enlighten providers and the community
on access to Safe abortion and when the
law is changed and I think the second
important thing is to make sure that the
health system is actually able to
deliver these services this includes
training insufficient amount of staff
task sharing amongst different caters of
providers and making sure that the
equipment and infrastructure you need to
access Safe abortional Care particularly
medication abortion which is new and
very helpful for when many women is
existence in health facilities and at
the community level and have you seen
any sort of changes uh across the
continent
realized their laws recently beneathome
and Principe Sierra Leone and Liberia in
the works some countries haven't
specifically liberalized their laws but
they've created expanded Health System
policies like Ethiopia and Ghana where
women are able to access Care at Health
Facilities with very little burden
um outside of the policy space there's
also been a growing body of work by ngos
csos and activists to increase access to
medication abortion which women can take
by themselves safely at home
and talking about stigma there's there's
the religious angle where you have
touched on many Africans whether a
Christian or Muslim say abortion is
against their religion now what's your
response to that
uh well full disclosure I am Christian
and my faith is a core part of who I am
and I'm not going to attempt to speak
for all Christians but for myself I
broadly believe you can't legislate
morality
um I think scripture says this um I also
think that we cannot create laws and
governing systems based on what we feel
or what we believe because we all
believe different things the Bible does
say give unto Caesar what is Caesar and
unto God what is God abortion is health
care and medical science has advanced
dramatically to make it safe for women
and to reduce the risk of morbidity and
mortality so by restricting abortion
basically what we're doing contravancy
Christian faith because we're trying to
punish women for having unintended
pregnancies and we're condemning them to
die by exposing them to the risk of
unsafe abortion so I don't think that if
anyone has a religion that follows a
code of Love or believes in a second
chance we should be making abortions
restricted
that was onike ololabi physician and
maternal Health researcher